i'm thinking about the phase of your
life where you discovered joni mitchell
and i don't think enough is made about
this
i think in all fairness i think joni was
so talented
that i think it would have happened
anyway i think so
but who knows you're the guy you're the
one who discovered her
i i it wasn't like i had a choice man
she was so good i couldn't ignore it
she is arguably the best
singer-songwriter
of our times i i think she's as good a
poet
as bob and she's ten times the musician
and singer that he is
i care about him but the truth is she's
much better as a musician and much
better
as a singer and i don't get along with
her that well anymore but i i
i do love her with my whole heart
for what she gave us you know i don't
think anybody did it as well
this they've been celebrating blue
because it's 50 years since she made it
i think that's arguably the best
singer-songwriter record ever made
much better than my stuff i'm sad when
you say
you don't get along with joni i
understand you guys were boyfriend and
girlfriend for a while you broke up that
happens to lots of people
uh you know it's not just me i don't
think johnny gets along with any of her
exes so
we'll see this is why you are a hippie
graham dated joanie you dated joni
no hard feelings i was very happy when
she went with graham uh
graham was i think the best of us for
her the best
experience she had one another with a
guy with graham
you know i think james was good i think
jackson was good but
i think i think graham was the best of
us for her
did the the best at being her old man i
think it's the happiest she was
ever was do you think it's hard to date
a woman like that when you have such
respect for her talent right
yeah listen imagine if you wrote a song
a really good song
and you sang it to her when she came
home and then she sang you
three better songs that you wrote last
night
thank you for being honest i would find
that stifling i could not deal with that
stifling no but it might shrivel you up
a little bit yep
yeah and it's hard to have sex with
someone if they're writing that well
because you're like
absolutely is so why can't she
understand that did you try to explain
to her you're too much of a powerhouse
for me to be your boyfriend i can't
handle it we worked it out man you know
uh the best we could
and uh i'm grateful for the time i spent
with her
she taught me a lot she's an incredible
artist and that's the truth
the craziest story i heard about you
guys was that
you were you were the boyfriend of joni
mitchell and she broke up with you
singing she wrote a song about you you
wrapped peter tork's house from the
monkeys and she decided to sing this
song to you which essentially said
hey david i'm breaking up with you that
is that's even funnier than that
she came in and she was kind of
different you know she said i've got a
new song and we all said
we were all there and we all said oh
fantastic a new journey song yay
and she sits down to sing it and it's
plainly a goodbye to me
and then she sang it again
why twice in case you didn't get it
because i didn't get it the first time
unbelievable unbelievable does everyone
in the room
does everyone in the room turn to
everybody in the room was going oh
who's in the room with you guys watching
this everybody
it's this one it's numerically funny you
want a song written about you but not
like this right
not that one no
what a voice though